I've done so many [ __ ] intrest have
to go inbred you see this rock that
means it's time for sum up what my pay
your own air last episode like I didn't
fail
I was just intentionally not solving
anything whoa what the [ __ ] are we
alright let's go this way round three
fight let's just do it okay the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] hey men ha
yes that's exact no am I was that his
[ __ ] did it
what what did I just see uh-huh okay
let's jump to a military base oh sorry
alien base there's a robot me buddy a
dough out I don't grab my balls okay I'm
creeped out but I'm so many things at
once right now uh uh what am i doing oh
no Batman do something I'm just standing
on dance that was not a solution okay
let's take the dynamite go inside him
this is if this is his [ __ ] this is
what in my solution thank God okay
oh and we move on to next one oh now
we're inside his [ __ ] and it's clouds
outside which is really nice I can see
the clouds moving holy [ __ ] alright we
don't have a lot of time old man how the
hell did you get into this mod give me
that
okay well okay thank you can't have it
all Kenya let's just go to the alien hey
man how you done
let me bum your head because that's what
you do when you encounter an ATM Thank
You mcpixel for that now we're on the
bus and Batman wants its fire
extinguisher here you go bra I love your
movies there you go this is my tribute
thank you for [ __ ] out this foam
thank you so much okay let's take the
dynamite shove it out of his [ __ ] I
know just fine let me touch the computer
that didn't solve anything
just like in real life let's hax this
bad man do something with this
thank you no it's not what I wanted
right Batman
they told me I could become anything so
I became a microchip good good on you
good on you man thank you for that okay
this is part two where a microchip and
we're gonna click the timer what's the
least okay I got this that was not a
solution take the dynamite and give it
to the old man Yes No
did we just become boobies on an old man
that makes sense at least cuz that was
what I was going for it let's take the
bomb give it to the robot hey you go bro
yes inside it's ah-ah-ah there's a lot
of poop joke going on right now I don't
know if we're in a row bud bud yes yes
part two of robobot mcpixel
no what what third 3dx
what Wow as a whole here it's difficult
take it then I saw that what's going on
that was not a solution what is he doing
right now I'm so confused by everything
and I just I just kind of lost it I just
think anymore I guess I got the brain
damage warning they talk too much what
am i doing okay yeah up we did that one
talk to me I clicked everything huh
click that what about these I don't know
what what am i doing there's something
there Oh
shame oh no no no no no I got it put it
here yeah yeah I bet you weren't
expecting that were you
Mack beard here the last one okay think
kids thing I don't know why I repeat
stuff and think that magically somehow
it's gonna work itself out
well maybe this one well maybe this one
maybe this one okay we officially click
everything except these yeah that kinda
looks like a dynamite [ __ ] blows up
anyway okay we need to think here yeah
[Music]
sorry Mack that was good
that was really good let's go this
direction I love that pink at round 2
fight doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo we're
at the wedding
maybe circus I don't wedding and he's a
wizard the priest why am I getting
married
is that it Wyatt where's the groom come
on kicking the grew drag ridin whatever
okay what's going on here let's just go
out hello how big I am compared to the
door like what the [ __ ] perspective and
beer belly
ow ow right in the pan Ana's do not cool
up with a lady girl
up girl tough girl
oh well we found the bomb at least what
the [ __ ] what's going on here
what is this do you want this yes of
course we do that we guess yes yes thank
you Chinese restaurant hey fat lady man
take the poke ball take it oh that I
became a Pokemon it's not every day you
can say that okay let's take the gun and
shoot the man it's usually the man
causes trouble ya know why did he do it
I loved him all right give me that
I mean casts a spell on you no holy [ __ ]
a bite but now we up she ate it and now
you will explode yeah what is he doing
still talking well [ __ ]
macaroni oh okay
I got this one don't worry rest how am I
so big compared to this car get it okay
let's pick on the Sun I like nice
weather take it back Oh for [ __ ] sake
halation okay what about her [ __ ] can
we do the same as we did a lil man take
it girl yes yes that was exactly what I
was going for thank you for that
okay let's not become a Pokemon let's
make the dynamited Pokemon
go deines more I don't know what's going
on I think no that was not a solution
okay don't kill yourself bro you kill
here ah stop peeing on people mic picks
out what am i doing another epic
solution yes it's so easy to see it I
can't believe I didn't think about it
before
alright breath ahh stop doing that
alright thundering and camera out why
why I don't that doesn't change anything
oh [ __ ] me I'll just become a Pokemon
then not we did that nope didn't do
anything here you go a lady eat it yeah
that's right pay that [ __ ]
good job girl thank you so much let's
just take the [ __ ] bomb from her poor
grab-grab but what are you do why do I
have to take this thing god damn it
hold on a second alright last chance for
me here let's take the dynamite what
okay no I did that
let's give her thunder you once under
girl Wow I wanted to just take the
dynamite ah [ __ ] it
breasts I'm sorry my hair over here I've
tended Hibbert but occupation dude just
gotta cover it today and I'll see you
next episode of whatever I mean well I
mean whatever
I'm a girl alright alright alright bro
come out I know you're [ __ ] in there
come out come out come out hey you want
to play all right one what what what